and welcome to Hannity we begin tonight
with a Fox News Alert earlier today as
we have accurately predicted right here
on this show the Inspector General
released the first in what will be a
series of damning reports regarding a
variety of topic now today's report as
we previously told you this is the small
baby one very narrow in scope dealing
specifically with only one issue that's
former FBI director Jim Comey and his
memos and in just a moment we're going
to break down all the details and what
was a devastating rebuke of the former
FBI director now while today's narrow IG
report is yeah small in scope the big
report by the Inspector General on FISA
abuse is expected to be detailed brutal
and devastating in its conclusions we
can tell you that we expect that report
to determine that those FISA warrants
the four warrants on Carter page the
backdoor spying on the Trump campaign
transition and presidency were in fact
the illegally obtained that's what we're
expecting
and remember Comey signed three of the
four warrant applications and the
original one which was October 2016
before the election but he told Trump
something else in January just before he
became president of 2017 now today was
the release of what is only a narrow
sliver of information and it's brutal a
small part of what will be coming in the
weeks ahead still the report that was a
stunning and harsh rebuke to the former
FBI director but let's be clear this
report this is exactly what a few weeks
ago we told you exactly what it would be
we were not wrong it's narrow limited in
scope with referrals that the AG is
declined to act on as of now now all of
this we reported to you weeks ago now
tonight we do know James Comey is in
fact not the super Patriot he claims we
know him to be a leaker and a liar the
inspector general at the Department of
Justice found that the disgraced former
FBI director quote set a dangerous
example for the 35,000 current FBI
employees and today's report was an
unprecedented rebuke of an FBI director
surrounding his nefarious plot to seek
revenge against President Trump by the
way it shows how political he was from
the very GetGo and as it turns out
America's self-proclaimed super Patriot
is nothing more than a dirty corrupt
former bureaucrat that will be in Syria
significantly legal jeopardy as this all
unfolds after he was fired we know today
that he lifted sensitive and in some
cases classified government memos about
conversations that he had with the
President of the United States and then
call me stored these documents at his
home and leaked these sensitive
documents and the contents of them one
of the memos to the press using a close
friend now a lawyer as a conduit that
went to the New York Times he also used
a personal email address to disseminate
classified material to his own lawyers
you're supposed to get the approval of
the FBI he didn't get that approval
among the many serious violations let's
go through the list the inspector
general found that quote commis
retention handling dissemination of
certain government memos violated
department and FBI policies and his FBI
employment agreement Comey did not seek
authorization from the FBI before
providing sensitive government memos to
his attorneys he's supposed to do that
additionally Comey did not seek FBI
authorization before providing the
contents of memo for through Richmond to
a reporter that reporter at The New York
Times Comey told the Office of Inspector
General that he did not notify anyone at
the FBI that he was going to share these
memos with anyone Comey violated
applicable policies and his employment
agreement by failing to either surrender
his copies of the memos to the FBI or to
seek authorization to retain them now
once he knew that the FBI had classified
portions of memo to call me failed to
immediately notify the FBI that he had
previously given memo to to his
attorneys and despite knowledge that
memo three contained classified
information
Comey did not appropriately mark memo
three with classification banners
portion markings or a classification
Authority block Comey violated
negative order 13526 an intelligence
community department and FBI policies
governing marking of classified
information call me was not authorized
to disclose the statements that he
attributed to President Trump in memo
for which were relevant to the ongoing
Flint investigation Comey was also in
clear violation of the FBI's well
pre-publication review policy now I can
go on and on because this memo today
went on and on there are 79 pages 79
devastating pages documenting commis
gross misconduct and this is just as I
said this is one small sliver this is
only the tip of the iceberg today's
report is solely and very narrowly
focused on commis illicit leaking and
mishandling of sensitive government
memos and retaining such now that's just
one small little part of commis web of
corruption now this is the low-hanging
fruit if you're looking for the bigger
picture so while the Attorney General
bar is declining to prosecute or are
clear criminal violations for now we
expect several more damning bombshell
reports in the coming weeks including
the big Pfizer report and as we have
mentioned the investigation and defies
abuse will likely detail how Comey and
others well that they committed
premeditated fraud against the FISA
Court in that case call me sworn that
swore that the evidence and the FISA
application was verified that it was
corroborated that it was true and
multiple renewals by the way
similarly were verified corroborated and
true the warrant request was marked
verified at the very top of the document
in other words the FISA application
verified it's right there now the
evidence was not true it was not
accurate and it was never verified in
fact we have pointed out on this program
we now know it was unverifiable its
claims deemed unverifiable and when the
FBI finally got around to looking into
the veracity of it oh they determined 90
plus percent if not all of it was false
yet the warrant was used
the bulk of information to get the
warrant against quarter-page but also a
backdoor to spy on the communications of
the Trump campaign the Trump transition
team and the president according to Fox
News legal analyst gray jarrett quote it
can be a felony to conceal relevant
information and deceive the FISA Court a
half a dozen statutes make it a crime to
perpetuate a fraud on the court
including deprivation of Rights 18 USC
242 perjury 18 USC 1621 1623 and false
statements 18 USC 1001 then of course
you can answer that several obstruction
of justice and fraud statutes that all
would be applicable now those are
devastating charges Comey and others
could be facing in the coming weeks but
that's not all another massive
investigation which I believe will
become the biggest part of all of this
abuse of power and corruption all that
surrounds the origins of the Russia
witch-hunt now that probe now being
conducted by the Attorney General and by
John Durham is now focused on how James
Comey how John Brennan James clapper
others weaponized the powerful tools of
intelligence that we entrust to these
brave men and women in our intelligence
community and how they weaponized them
against all things Donald Trump now
whether or not the Obama abide
administration this is going to be the
big question in all of this solicited
foreign Intel agencies well to
circumvent American law to do the spying
that they can't do on the Trump campaign
and other Americans that would be a
really serious crime the bigger issue
becomes why did President Obama begin a
counterintelligence investigation
against an incoming president he will
have to answer those questions now
there's no counterintelligence campaign
that doesn't happen it's never conducted
unless it is a president's that means
the president had to have knowledge and
we know from the struck page of course
texting that yeah he wanted to be
informed the White House wanted to be
informed every step of the way
you might also remember the odd email
Susan Rice to herself on the very day of
Trump's inauguration remember this she
randomly documented a conversation with
President Obama about the Russia
witch-hunt writing quote President Obama
began the conversation by stressing his
continued commitment to ensuring that
every aspect of this issue is handled by
the intelligence and law enforcement
communities by the book Wow so Donald
Trump's being inaugurated as president
that and it all happened weeks ago why
did she feel the need to write that cya
note to self why don't you feel the need
to send herself a memo on Obama's last
day in Trump's first day and more
importantly Obama Biden Rice Lynch
Brennan clapper call me what did all of
these people know about this
counterintelligence investigation and
when did they know it and what was the
justification for it and as for super
Patriot Jim Comey he's still living in
that alternative reality of his he's
claiming on Twitter today and elsewhere
that today's report totally absolves him
of any wrongdoing
just the opposite Jimbo